All right, prophecy. Now think of it this way.
If the Bible is both accurate and trustworthy and
we can know it to be true, but we can also know it to be historical,
what then does that say about prophecy?
Prophecy is tricky.
It's almost like we can believe that the Bible is accurate history.
We can show that and it's concrete and it kind of lines up with some other things.
And we can show that the Bible is completely accurate across all of history and that
it's 95% the same exact thing that what Jesus actually said or
whatever.
But prophecy is trickier because prophecy can be something
that you might just discount out and go well that just sort of was the happenstance
or just coincidence it just sort of happened that way or maybe it was manufactured
to look like it was fulfillment of prophecy
so here's the deal with this week as you go through piece by
piece as you walk students through the misconceptions and the illuminations as you
walk your students through and help guide them through their introduction
activity and exploration of Isaiah chapter 52 and 53.
As you look at the questions and you start to piece this whole week together, I want
you to keep one thing in mind this week and that's it.
This week could be a difficult week.
This could be the week, one of those weeks, that students start firing all kinds of
questions at you especially your small group leaders so
here's what we're going to do
we're going to write the questions down and we're going to dig in do some research
and I want you to come back if you have to even take an additional week to
answer those questions don't pretend like you have all the answers now you might
have a bunch of the answers and that's awesome but if you don't don't pretend and
don't brush it off because we're sort of at that moment now where you probably have
students that are like especially if they started very skeptical hopefully they're
walking closer and closer and closer and closer but the closer you get
the easier it is to just fall off the edge because if we discount
a question and the train may just come off the rails and it just may be over.
I don't know. So you want to approach these kinds of things very carefully.
You've spent so much time and energy in developing authentic and organic community
and trust with these students and openness and honesty and being able to ask the
difficult questions. Now is one of those times where the difficult questions are
going to start to come. When it comes to prophecy, there just may be those kinds of
things.
And I can't predict what kind of questions your students may ask.
But from my experience, this is always one of those areas that just, it pops up.
So if you don't know the answers or your small group leaders don't know the answers,
write them down, gather together, get some answers,
bring your students back together and give them the answers that they're seeking.
So for this week, don't be afraid to directly address the misconception.
And here's how we've worded it. It seems to be entirely impossible for one man to
fulfill hundreds of prophecies. Not to mention that the way Jesus fulfilled
Messianic prophecy was very much contrary to popular Jewish theology.
Jewish leaders were looking for the coming Messiah to be a political, military, and
spiritual ruler that would dethrone foreign rule and re-establish Israel as a world
superpower.
Instead, Jesus unexpectedly established his spiritual kingdom.
It's a worldview shift that has prevented many from accepting him as Savior.
Keep that in mind. This is a completely world, complete worldview shift
for many. It was that way for the Jews in the first century and it's that way
probably for many of your students as well don't be afraid to hit the